that's the police they're calling
killers hours after the first major
climbed down by the Hong Kong leader
protesters were screaming abuse at them
the white flowers are in mourning for
the hundreds arrested amid repeated
claims of police brutality the chief
executive called what looked very much
like an emergency meeting at her
residence and then announced a huge
u-turn the full withdrawal of the hated
extradition bill which would have seen
suspects sent to China incidents over
these past two months have shocked and
saddened Hong Kong people we are all
very anxious about Hong Kong our home we
all hope to find a way out of the
current impasse and unsettling times
this was happening as the Hong Kong
leader was contemplating her dramatic
decision her first concession comes
after three months of protests and
increasingly violent confrontations like
these and now the activists are in no
mood to give up we have got this far and
there is a lot of people being
sacrifices that and or even arrest and
hurt by the Hong Kong police this is
what's prompted such anger and the
demonstrators demands include an
investigation into police behavior it's
led to many injuries we spoke to one hit
by a police rubber bullet we have been
trying peaceful protests for two for a
long time and they just make us to use
violence go test has it put you off
protesting being wounded like this has
it made you scared to protest everything
even more I am scared but I still will
protest but the protesters have grown
increasingly aggressive burning
barricades and over the weekend lobbing
more than a hundred petrol bombs at
police
those we spoke to in a cafe on Hong Kong
Island weren't all supportive of the
tactics being used by the protesters you
know my peaceful life in Hong Kong and
making this easily destroyed - his whole
life and for my what started out as fury
over an extradition bill has turned into
so much more with claims of police
brutality right at the centre of it it's
going to be very hard for the chief
executive to keep a lid on this and the
city will be bracing itself to see if
there'll be more violent protests this
weekend
Alex Crawford Sky News Hong Kong